the Russo brothers have struck again the
filmmaking pair have previously admitted
to including scenes in the trailers of
their marvel films that are misleading
or downright absent from the finished
product and it turns out avengers
endgame was no different let's break the
deception down spoilers ahead first
considered this shot of Thor glancing
meaningfully at Stormbreaker this is
quite obviously a massive red herring
not only did the shot appear nowhere in
the film but Thor looks nothing like
this for the majority of endgame after
the film's five-year time jump early on
we see that the god of thunder has been
drowning his sorrows and the recently
established new Asgard the trailers fake
out is almost certainly a take from the
infinity war shoot most likely meant to
make us believe that the Avengers would
have to revisit the Battle of Wakanda
and give Thor one more shot at going for
the head you should have gone for the
head speaking of that time jump some of
the more misleading moments from the
trailers seem to be designed to throw us
off the scent of that particular plot
point for example Black Widow is seen
with her infinity war style blonde locks
when Scott Lang arrives at the Avengers
compound in the trailer but in the movie
this takes place after the jump and
Natasha's hair has mostly gone back to
its natural red shade the shot of
Natasha getting down with a little
target practice was omitted from the
film altogether as was a shot of her
sitting outside in the rain in Japan
while on the trail of Clint Barton
another seemingly random alteration the
exchange between Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers before the pair jump back to 1970
to retrieve the tesseract and more Pym
particles while the dialogue exchange in
the trailer is the same as the scene in
the film the handshake appears to have
simply been added to the promo spots for
dramatic effect and to let us know that
yes the two Avengers have finally mended
fences a more significant difference
here is caps uniform while in the
trailers it's the updated version from
infinity war in the movie it's his
Avengers era original outfit it's pretty
easy to see why this was done cap was
sporting his old duds in order to blend
in during the time-traveling excursion
to the Battle of New York
a few other shots seemingly ended up on
the cutting room floor for no reason in
particular except perhaps the shave a
few minutes off end games mammoth run
time
these include Bruce Banner agonizing
over the display showing all of the
missing and presumed dusted heroes
Clinton Natasha sharing a private moment
and a poignant shot of Tony Stark's face
as he uses his crashed Iron Man helmet
to record a message to Pepper Potts
while the drift in space one other
curious exclusion captain Marvel's
helmet which she was seen wearing in the
trailer but not during her triumphant
return during endgames climactic battle
there's only one reason we can think of
for this to hide Carol Danvers new
haircut which she sports after the time
jump finally there's another much more
significant change having to do with
another Captain Steve Rogers who was
seen in both the trailer and the film
cinching up the straps on a shield a
look of grim determination on his face
as all hell appears to be breaking loose
around him the spots version of the
sequence is identical to the one in the
movie save for one critical detail caps
shield is whole and unbroken in the film
it's been busted nearly in half after a
severe pummeling by Thanos making Rogers
action all the more badass as he
prepares to charge the mad Titan with
his trusty weapon shattered beyond
repair you gotta hand it to the Russos
they're dead serious about delivering
exciting trailers while preserving some
of their biggest secrets as we saw when
the trailers for infinity war led us to
believe that a fully hulked out banner
would be present at the Battle of
Wakanda when he in fact was forced to
suit up in Starks Hulkbuster armor due
to the not so Jolly Green Giant refusing
to come out to play indeed we're gonna
have to go ahead and say that their
trailer trickery is appreciated as
endgame spots held back details that we
frankly wouldn't have won it spoiled for
us when you're building one of the
biggest event films in history sometimes
you got to give the audience what they
don't know they want like a heaping
helping of deception check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]